[Music]
hi Conan O'Brien here I work on camera
which means I have to always look my
best you don't just get a body like this
so I have to work out constantly the
problem is where do you get the time
that's why I thought of the cone drone
drone drone get in here cone drone go to
the gym work out really hard for about
two hours and get me in fantastic shape
let's go
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
whoo yeah what a workout time to hit the
showers
unfortunately we are unable to show you
the rest of the workout due to a legal
action initiated by a miss Jennifer
Pettigrew of Studio City California
there's also a suit pending with the
ridge valley workout center of Burbank
now personally I think miss Pettigrew is
overreacting just a bit I mean come on
there are plenty of co-ed showers in
Europe I don't think it such a my lawyer
insists that I have no further comment
on this matter other than to say the
cone drone is a fine piece of technology
and we apologize to miss Pettigrew for
any embarrassment
you a real lair